a record of more than 200 000 viewers
tuned in to watch the final classical
game of the fide world championship
between yanya pandashi and ding lyron
the players did not disappoint with
dramatic play from the beginning ding
insisted on maximum activity and
aggression throughout with an early
night sack with Knight G5 and H4 it says
fire on board this strategy though
crowd-pleasing backfired as nepo
countered well claimed an edge and
looked to pick up a pawn in the end game
that's not a good move for two reasons
right the critical moment arrived on
move 36 when Rook B3 would likely have
won the Eva bar swings back down towards
equality but the slower E5 allowed ding
a brilliant resource in 38 B6 setting up
rook takes E8 check England keeps it
precise keeps it accurate the resulting
Pawn down rook in game was drawn though
it took several more hours to prove it
creating the longest game in the match
good handshakes and it's a drop tomorrow
it will all come down to Winner Takes
all tie breaks